To perhaps get you a little more comfortable with looking at first order logic,
we're going to parse this a piece at a time. First,
we are concerned with valid concrete states T. In which all the invariants,
that is invC corresponds to concrete invariants, hold on that state. Now
consider the corresponding abstract states and remember the retrieve function.
We can go from the concrete states to the abstract states by using the retrieve
function. If we are in the abstract state, the corresponding abstract state. And
we want to execute the abstract operation with arguments, some argument list,
called args here. Then of course, it's preconditioned. Which we've
indicated with the prefix ERE, on the retrieve state,
and the arguments must hold. If the abstract precondition does hold, and if
we have implemented the operation successfully. Then the concrete precondition,
which has the, uses the Q version on the concrete state t, must also hold.